[Laughter]
hey what's up how you guys doing some
guy went to sleep at 9 41 central
standard time
so [ __ ] that guy
no one knows i don't know what happened
to the footage
maybe it's out there somewhere rainy
pears
i hit start streaming why did she didn't
see it i'm streaming but i'm not live
what does that mean
anyways it wasn't
who wants this hey sheep
and brick i'm going to do wood
no one has it
and then i do this
you can exchange four yes
what the [ __ ] do you need me to explain
the rules to you i'm just trying to
american that's what you threw it out
yeah
yeah
you can exchange four that's how you ask
that
five
oh
three dollars to use on your next order
so you guys want to eat something
let's get a delivery oh [ __ ] it works
i'll probably do it this time because
last time you wanted to it's three in
the morning okay
early enough oliver tree
it was a lullaby train
uh probably because you played it last
time so much too
much i like all of this career
yeah
what's the song about
that's impressive
uh whose turn is it
me
i'll visit himself
no that's great you're doing great
green feels bad why would you feel bad
there's no reason for that okay
do you want to order pizza
11.
who wants i need brick
please brick
please
brick brick brick
hey brag
[Music]
seven
i guess it's going to be me
because everyone
shares with them
unless you specifically [ __ ] doing
overall seriousness
little off
how i turn it off
it's your phone
you know how to turn off like how it
locks all the time
i'm not familiar with iphone
oh yeah
i heard of all sometimes
wait
dude is anyone else coming like you
don't like that it keeps
blocking blocking
was that a mistake giving david my phone
no
it's just like he's uploading all your
videos
holy [ __ ] you weren't doing the scion
this whole time i know i'm just really
actually
i usually would just be in general
my favorite part
not take a card right no
okay
face id and pass code
[Music]
look at the song and music video like uh
like a suicide note
searching no no it's fine he's
he's an amazing artist
that's just how i feel because of what i
saw right after he passed away
and then murals of him went up all over
la oh yeah
well yeah there's one wall on hollywood
and highland that has murals of mac
miller amy winehouse and anthony
bourdain all next to each other
the saddest wall of the world they
didn't hang out no
that didn't hang out
did he get a [ __ ] from amy
no
thanks to you
anybody needs sheep
a brick
no all right then i'm gonna leave my
turn
wow
um
well you said something you're gonna put
this on london yeah right here
but
your phone
boot shoots on the mac option i have to
unlock it
tv
iphone
disconnect
from tv
free
i'll do it for an hour
i'm all disconnected
i think i'm just going to study
i'm not even sending a signal out i just
put on airplane mode
okay sorry that we didn't
know that it wasn't going live for for a
while it doesn't require yeah be two
streets away from these streets i don't
know
the streets
three you need more wood neck
center font i do need more wood yeah do
you guys hate
i'm sure okay
let me know what sent upon two rules
okay you do it for two heck
somewhere and then i could use milton
road
just giving you points
oh man
it's my second time playing okay
you're going to build the settlement too
then you break now
but
choosing strategy when you really don't
have to try to hear again
five
coming up here live from texas where we
survived the winter storm how did you
survive the winter storm
thank you
you're all by survivor stayed inside and
i
ate a lot of bread
oh what a [ __ ]
anyways
i uh hunkered up i left the faucet strip
did you guys do the faucet dripping
thing oh yeah
don't
you stock up any food
you didn't i know actually ran out of
grocery rides that happened
of course
people were acting a little wild
yesterday like there was always one day
and i mean i had like cans of tuna and
factory
[Music]
yeah i mean
it's just like we're practicing
panicking like a fire drill
okay but it's like we're traumatized
we've been through a lot
especially
the whites
they've had it rough
most of all
special so sorry
no a little 20-minute special you put
out on youtube akash singh
the guy from flagrant with andrew
schultz
oh nice
that's so good i saw just a little clip
save updo
isn't that hassan minaj
oh no that's
hari kantabali or
oh yeah
what did you say
totally different
you're gonna get laughed out of the
united emirates like that
does anybody have any mistake they want
to give up for wood
or for
your ass
for what
you know
no all right 2a for a break
it's a brick
okay
[Music]
you're too brave
um
haha
[Music]
the nearest domino's pizza and get us a
slice of [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
everything
dominoes i already told you you're a
computer be better
dominoes please
you're wrong
why are you helping me almost
[Music]
you're doing great
you're gonna get it
[Music]
you have over seven cards
doesn't nick look like something from
a wes anderson movie with that hat on
and that mustache
does he look like a sad sailor
i get that eight
wants to help me move tomorrow
i have one otherwise i would
all right and that's gonna be my turn
[Music]
who are the six
you're all seven
four
white
six
we're using a new laptop
an acer
upgraded
me
what
cool hi
are you done
what are you watching yourself foreign
let's see what people are saying about
sexy boy next year what sections about
me
are you done
somebody ever
somebody have um
do you have a brick
or something are you doing a tree or
i was trying to figure out a bluetooth
phone
but it wasn't working
you got it
about me
all right
[Music]
[Music]
right here
i don't know exactly
you really know is it okay
go to settings
just cool all right really just my turn
all right the local tv phone
sorry i don't know why i keep going it's
weird i was just
i know i shouldn't even be getting
anything
whoa you guys are smoking cbd on the
live podcast
helps with the implementation you guys
we can't admit that we're smoking
marijuana
yeah but if we can't say it's
marijuana no i'm just an oregano
we're not smoking marijuana that would
be highly illegal snake eyes
what's illegal i'm smoking marijuana
outside my favor
more water is a drug
it's a drug it's a schedule one narcotic
i thought it was a plan what's the plan
dude
now i'm gonna
down for quests they both want numbers
and i don't have another creative one
for me
no
we're doing it all wrong
we did the roku remote is what we need
well you're just gonna
no one's in there
because he's rolling
make yourself useful for once again
marijuana
yeah it's a secret
between all
oh my god
[ __ ]
so is it
just it's your first
oh god
i'm so sorry dude
yeah it's connected he wants you to be
healthy who's really trying to say hi
because you want you around that's
either
oh who put that there that's so rude
okay
who wants wood i have
i need i need sheep and i need
wheat do you have ore
i have wood
one two three four five six seven eight
okay go ahead
you're like a grandpa but he's 3 30
years old
10 10.
so
i'll order us some dominoes the first in
stream history
new uh new sponsor
what do you want domino's or are we more
a papa john's kind of guys
dominoes over papa john's papa john's is
trash
i know it's a dude i want like a
faceless corporation
domino's television
[Music]
reveal this card on your turn with it
you reached the number of points
required oh years oh
you made an ass of yourself
not in the beginning
you're so proud you came so early
i felt like it was required for victory
you're not victorious
you could have hidden that and until
you're notorious like you're really not
quiet
why too like you're literally [ __ ]
beautiful is that your territories
well once they're gonna look up maps
oh this is enough for victory here i
deserve victory now
yes
you're complete but food
it's been like a drink
down the nose thanks
thank you yeah
it's damn oh okay six now
dominoes i beckon the upon us
all right everyone
get your [ __ ] together
so are you done
i'll leave those with down
dude
what the [ __ ]
domino's is supposed to be there for us
yes
hey what's
up this isn't the domino spirit
are you done
anybody want wood or hay or sheep for an
ore oh my god
or any any metal these people are more
iron ore are they here or out their
hands no all right then it's my turn
four five six seven
dominus
once we
your sheep
[Music]
people in the comments saying papa
john's isn't trash so your fan base
might be uh
john's
favorite so maybe you want to listen to
that
maybe i the italian fat buck doesn't
know what he's talking about
before when it comes to pizza
or
hello
you do
delivery
oh thanks
like who's that
some [ __ ] guy that's
not
doing his job who was closed
dominus should we go for let's try papa
john's pop
is that the only alternative the fans
well those are the only two options you
gave i thought you would know the pizza
in your neighborhood i don't know the
pizza in my neighborhood don't assume
that i know the pizza in my neighborhood
i do not know this you got tree for
brick or sheep
a tree for a ripper i'm that tree for
no
that's my turn
dude this is an armageddon situation
armageddon everyone's just forsaking
their duties oh i didn't even move my
[ __ ] robber
god damn it
leave it there
oh no i ain't i'd throw the seven oh
nice
you already won
yes steal the car from it
yeah
there's no pizza places open right now
if anyone does anyone need sheep
or brick
cheap for a brick or ore
nope all right then it is your turn
you want to try double dave's pizza
works
6 12
two
four i'll give you a call
see if anyone wants to work around here
hold on sweet
i need sheep
he [ __ ]
who wants wood
i have wheat and oil
i need sheep
meat lovers
sausage
get a lodge meat lover's pizza
hi do you guys see delivery
hi i'd like a large meat lovers pizza
please
yes please
yes
are you making a statement right now
i feel offended that your
rolling out a pizza box
would you roll we could have
only seven
however you're right
yeah i'm growing livestream
that one
is it seven or more it's like a seven i
have to get rid of three
yeah my name is hans h-a-n-s
oh yeah
8 32.
i have to let you in
one large meat lovers pizza
yeah
let's get a thick one and is it
yeah do you guys have stuffed with
cheese option
okay yeah i i want like a thick one
please
no not that thick just like a normal
not thin crust
it's like a medium grass
burn
yes please
do you guys have any like cinnamon
sticks
i'll take one of those
that's pretty much it
credit card
[Music]
i'll pay in cash i'll tip the delivery
driver
okay thank you very much
bye
better at my [ __ ] pizza
what's that
you want to get the ball in
oh it's all it's been on the whole time
no i turned it on right when i said the
unit number
yeah it's uh i would not want my address
out there or the part of her number
you throwing navara
tomorrow
i thought it was yeah
what if they killed you in the morning
well whose train is it is it my turn i
rolled the seven i moved it here
and then i'm gonna
go
she rolled the joy for us
thank
you
which one do i smoke out of this side
and then do you think it's pretty
yeah this one's prettier does anybody
need lemon or sheep
or wood
i need sheep
do you have uh ore no or brick nope
what about you or for anything
iron ore
i need a sheep and a brick i can give
you a sheet
i need to be a sheep and a wood
i know i need a sheep and a brick from
her horn but that's my turn then
seven
really
yes
if i want to exchange for another item i
need four of it right
yeah yeah okay
you're gonna give up half your cards
yeah
who wants wood i need sheep
you don't need you don't know that
you're taking one from me yeah
i do that right
they have sheep eight cardboard four
already yeah you have four cards
they're i was wondering
i could just take your sheets
unless you want me to take something
more valuable
you want this bag
you took what you took can i uh can i
also trade him for a card right now no
you can't trade in right now
you have sheep nick
no i don't you have wheat
if she do you want wheat how many are
you willing to give one i'll take two
what about a sheep a wheat and a wood
for one sheep
you'll do that you want wheat
you said what about wood
look at that
can't be dealing with none of your broke
asses
this song on right now
you heavy leave me
you know i had no idea that song i i
listened to it for probably a decade and
i had no idea that it's called
where he raps over this
piano
but the whole time listen to that song
without realizing it was this song by
band of horses i wouldn't have ever
known that
thank you for lightening me
seven damn
what a night
go to vegas
i'm also going to train
these four
trees
what if you pick up
a sheep
what would you do that
why wouldn't you just pick something
from someone first and then trade it in
is this so good to hear point
i know but what if you get a sheep now
all right um
i don't have any cards
[Music]
what are you muttering about
so you're gonna move this oh yeah
that's i forgot your name again i'm
gonna call this nicholas okay
more like specialist he's
mexican
you are nope i don't know
we're all a little mexican sometimes i
mean i come from california so that's
nice
all right like one time i have an oar
for a break if they misguided
nothing yeah it sounds like this on
amazon
cool
do i make a good dj yes she's an
excellent dj
thank you very much
they also make an excellent joint roller
oh i thank you sir
it smells like a [ __ ] twig
six
oh you can't
i know
nick
what did i do i got issues with you what
was it
you [ __ ] up the money that's what you
did
you never [ __ ] with the man's money
wow
finally
go ahead and act a precious commodity in
the game
seven
[Music]
because it's tobacco
[Music]
what shut up dude
oh yes
that's my turn
whoa
still spinning like a cradle
roll it again you have a filthy animal
eight
[ __ ]
okay well
i'm ready for him to pop up any moment
now
are you done rolling eights
seven
that you're wrong
to myself you're doing great
he needs brick for everything
and i can cut that off forever
it's like the last game
i had to get
from you
i need a sheep and your
[Music]
yeah three from that six yeah it's crazy
what you play at night
why are you moving the night roll to
seven or s oh no i didn't i wrote jesus
christ
what the [ __ ]
oh
where'd you play europe
one of these european rules
so we got a nice little game going on of
catan
you can see that the blue it's got a
snaking road
it's got the wheat port i got the two
sixes
oh you've got it damn we're fine
dude you can't do that just get somebody
at the port on that sorry
britain's always like they don't
pronounce the end of their t's
oh no i got it
they're supposed to go to hamburg
distracted
no with your brick covered
are you done nick
yeah
it happens
she got a sheep
is
check us out on
disney plus
um
um
what are you laughing at
me and that is kind of the
anyone want wood or rock or wheat
i need brick
where's brick
look at this
bro
i remember this
i think this is done
i think hans has this
i better put that hay part
i'm just gonna have to take a dice along
this road too
can you pull out llamas right
here
the seventh house
is
so what do you guys think about
brett morin he's in town
brett morin is at the vulcan right now
and tearing it up
two shows today two shows tomorrow
rolling into our town
taking rst
he's so likable he's like paul rudd
paul read likable yeah and don't age
that's really likable that's like called
ultimate like mobility right like he was
like there too and like
did uh uh
me yeah no
you need anything for or
anybody have a break
nope
change these four
that's going to be my turn
tenth
eight
interesting
okay
anyone want rock
what do you mean
brick
or a sheep
what about too weak
what do you have
three
the only thing that you have
would be
i don't have brick for you would
do you have wheat for me no
who wants this
you don't want rock
what about wheat you want me
go ahead
nine
thank god
oh man you changed it
it's like an eight-minute song
they put an ad in the middle of it they
kind of did so i changed it
no
advertisements
we used to not watch those when i was a
kid
we had commercials we had tevo
we had adblock
and we got these stupid roku sticks
well you know what i have like a little
thing i don't know if i have it with me
but you can connect directly to your
phone
i know it's amazing
water and stuff
i need some water
somebody wants something i got i got hay
for tr uh this is
for treat yeah how many
one and one yeah
yeah actually have to pass
right now no i'm going to say
thank you
have you ever been three times for no
no
good you have sheep no nope i don't have
anything that i need from you
eight uh okay okay what are you doing
i'm gonna build a city
four for red
one two three four five six one two
three
cheaper hamburgers
do you have sheep
yeah i'm good
okay dad yes
that's not
at all
i'm fumbling it doesn't crash it down
party card
well i have to beat this four of the
same kind right yeah
we can't do four different cards at us
we all have the same kind
are you done
when you traded in
trade i know he was just asking those
little newbies
yeah yeah i know that i thought you were
yeah
sorry about that
hey
anyone have sheep
you want brick
you want wheat you want rock i need a
sheep
all right
[ __ ] you guys
from here i will conquer the world
i could have saved
one card but it really wasn't
worth
even breaking up
four
oh cities get two uh-huh
oh my god
okay three plus two because five one
and he has a shape part but he has no
shape
right now
wonder how she's doing
you know where is she what's she up to
right now
like forever
is she alive
i'd be hard-pressed to find out
i mean i guess it's more polite than to
turn all the photos away right we have
an embraced family right i'm afraid that
right
nick is about to overload
you got this you're done
oh
buddy
i might have saved the game
slow pounds down again
a fool
and then yeah
yeah that's right so i put down five
threes indicating the part
right got five on that one last one
so what
i'm going to build
no one knows what you're talking about
slowly because will be one word with
sheep isn't she busy
and that was the birth and then i'd put
down for all five of my my word right
there either that was all
because i wrote so i had those people
what that [ __ ]
yeah i can't though because it's too
close huh can he build uh
[Music]
can he do that
or no no oh okay
we got to build another road
to do that or you could build here in
the build here
and you just built this on this turn
right
yeah so you can move it if you want or
you can just keep it there and build
another road
okay
yourself a lot
[Music]
um
you want that one back
just kidding
okay i don't know just
oh yeah
brick
oh my god one two three four five six
seven one two three four five six oh you
got the longest round now
buy another card
let's take a goodness
five now
no foreign
too much brick anyone want brick
everyone wants bricks
that's only four
that's five
okay whatever
all right go ahead
and you can see
i built the road right here and this
settlement is giving me rock of course
it's covered by a robber
then i got a lot of work coming in with
the six
hurries
speed
my father
why is he doing this
brother
what are you doing brother
oh kareem wants to come
come over kareem
he's from genji
dude david's having five minutes hour
that's such an old message
dj's killing it in the corner i need
like an or dj corner
a sheep for an award
i think that nothing
nope
what about what's up with those
they're paid for
what about um
well she brought hey front or
oh book
here it is so let's help you four
six
all right seven
six seven four
six no it's just six
one two three four five six
where's the woodport at
oh he's never getting there he could go
for this three in one
oh what do you mean
nothing
is
no okay
[ __ ] maybe now it was too busy watching
me explain when you said that to him
that the music cut for the next song
yeah
we should find a way
to like get rid of the gaps
maybe there's an app for them just
the lighting actually so if i'm like
this is because you're black and light
yeah
it's very sweet of you if the light
doesn't reach you that means you're not
being filmed
[Music]
you know
i'm having all of those
okay
whose turn is it
oh [ __ ]
that's cool
seven
one two three four five one two three
three four five
one two three nine dots over there
four dots
six dots
i roll the seven too get rid of half of
them
the [ __ ]
i'm like this is whatever happened to me
oh because you're not supposed to have
that many cards after a seven
yes
i told you to spend your cards i
couldn't buy anything you gotta mix and
match to figure something out
do you think she is reading this
shilling awkward i know
she does under
what i can't come
all the way philosopher nate doug once
said
smoke weed every day haha let me be lazy
bro
twenty dollars christopher cat
christopher castro
money for the booze
pool get some more bucket comics over
there bucket comments yeah
that's you
okay comics yeah what's that mean it
means good names in the bucket
oh cool
yeah yeah it's kind of
that's where it came out of
on when i was on ketone
yeah
we all starve for the bucket i'll start
from the bucket
some of us
uh
will never go back to it ever again even
if
i have to i won't do it
okay i'd like to do it again have
another good minute recorded
yeah
no i um
uh i hate bucket comics they're trash
cool
i thought i just had to do it
well you [ __ ] somewhere funny i thought
i just had to go to the hospital what
did you what did you do was teddy
graham's [ __ ] you up forgotten i eat
beets earlier
your dick is too big
what was wrong
seven and you're just getting rid of
half of them
yeah that's it you did okay now i get to
steal from it
okay
who wants wood or brick or rock and has
sheep or wheat
i haven't got any cards
just kidding
i'll build the road
okay actually i'm done thanks
ten
so what do you think about gerard
carmichael at the creek in the cave
tonight
sold out that's awesome
sold out i both had
this is just for practice show
how he advertised it he's there tomorrow
too huh can you imagine just being like
i'm not going to try
lower your expectations for this one
he's got that pool
yeah i mean people just want to see that
part of him
it's like oh it's
i truly wonder what he is is it pizza or
green
i think that's pizza
no
uh okay
sure okay
that's cool is that weird
no not at all
you didn't
[Music]
one sec
uh
[Music]
oh okay that's awesome thank you i'll be
right back okay
what's 35 divided by seven
did five is going by seven there were
five
yeah
oh yeah 35 divided by five is seven oh
wait i wanted to build a road i'm sorry
today
before you roll
i forgot don't forget
before you rolled i built my road okay
what a nerd
you're not gonna have been on
stream you have like 40 viewers right
now i'm sure everyone he knows probably
doesn't have that much
huge leadership they gave us an extra i
forgot and then it's correct
or something said they gave us one
that's good and one that's messed up
just for that prank that's why you gave
it to me it was personal that was like
the matrix like the oracle oh it's like
let's go
eat our boys
anybody need bread girl
or sheep
pizza
um
[Music]
[Music]
this is the cinnamon yeah
no it's the chocolate here this is
there we go
look at him he's just so content
he's never going to raise his heart rate
for anybody win this game
thank you thank you thank you
thank you
i should have found out about them
sooner
i'm about to move
is that a case
well prototype
no not really equidistant just to the
south south
yeah
thank you
as a pen
my hair yes
who wants rock
or brick or wood
i need wheat and i need sheep
no
okay perhaps we have we checked your
sheet for what
four yeah
or
what do you have what do you need
more sheet i don't know
i have that hey if you haven't
i'll do paper sheet
you thirsty thirsty little piggies
oh [ __ ] i can't even buy a thick [ __ ]
thing yet
god damn it can we do it back
please
i got
a bunch of useless
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
what
yes
is a good sauce
okay go
is there a sauce with it
oh
so you're like a pizza expert no
sorry
such a cool video
blair
but vibes
yeah are you done
um
yeah
or wait no i'm not
are you all i don't think you're wrong
um
what is the correct way once um
what the [ __ ]
i don't even know how i have that sheep
phrasing right
i think that was settlement
oh they're not feminists
oh
six
well
i am it's gonna be my turn
hey
i'm done your turn
so um what are you going to do
this coming week for comedy
i'm a
working sunset strip on the 10th and the
11th how are those shows been uh pretty
great
they're uh they're selling out nice time
i've been there
last show i did there we got 145
how do they get those people out there
i'm not to be sure i'm not sure their
marketing and practice they've been
doing it for over a year now so a lot of
those people are regulars nice
it just seems like very
mysteriously run
i was supposed to be in dallas
i didn't make it
i'm doing ariel isaac norman's heckling
show
that's it i'm doing a visit have you
known yourself
yeah that's all out there
it's awesome yeah
underutilized
there's other cinnamon stuff
and the pizza
fallout theater is great
problem with six
okay
it's a little improv though
four
here
ten
investment
no more food no i'm fine thank you
but thank you you're welcome
no not yet
soon i'm glad i know they're there
though
what should we do should we go downtown
i'm ready when you work
wait dave will be here five minutes
huh
what are you doing nick
okay let's do it
four for one
[Music]
does anybody have um
an ore for a sheep or trees
in order
[Music]
i don't know
i remember the eight yeah so but you
didn't pick up for it already no you
don't already have an arc no okay wait
when because i remember when did you
pick up when you roll an eight on the
north it was the last row oh then i mean
no
i know that's right they come on you get
your pick i saw your pictures i don't
know
nobody has any arm i do for a sheep or
tree
no good bribes
no i'm sorry because i have to scroll
through like the next few songs android
you know
andy
the longest turn ever i am sorry
my bill was settled here
yeah i was hot forgotten my turn
you play like
oh my god
earthquake
and then i'm going to
take bro
did you already pick up your ore i'm
looking at
okay this is the largest army right
yes
and you know seven two
you're done
seven
four five
six seven
into three times four this tone
you have rock
you want wheat for wood
did you take one from from yeah
you got a little china i need hay
okay you have rock no i breathe
city
right here
that way i can get more rock
and build cities elsewhere quicker
or
so many four you get so many for four
why
six right here
two two four five six
oh i gotta work too all right
that's on both of them right yeah six
six yeah
are you done
so
you're done i know
i'm going to strangers
um
jesus christ there are so many cries
how does he have so many cards
you're ending your turn with that many
cars i never prepared myself it's not
great
that's fine
literally
card
does anyone need brick
for
rock
brick for rock you want some hans
you have rock let me break i don't need
brick
in my turn
11.
completely annexed the map
i'm keeping you two apart
i'm definitely legit
i'm glad you said
look at that epic longest road right
there
it's only one minor inefficiency to
catch some more wood rock
i haven't heard it in a while
oh you could get him you keep building
that
another one
are you done
yeah
or doesn't mean we have tree for hay no
tree per day no like sheep for safe
right there
does anyone need bricks
[Music]
five
uh
who wants rock i need wheat
you can lose sheep i need raw and you
have sheep wheat cheap wheat
building something
five
jesus
that's so many cards
okay just
thank you
[Music]
nine points
don't anybody uh don't need i need a
brick for a hair for a hang
[Music]
[ __ ]
i'll give you a brick for everything in
your hand
five
three
two
three
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
still one short
that's my turn
three
you want rock
what about wood
no one two three
seven
seven
two three four five six seven
okay do you have to give up half your
cards
do i have to give it half my cards yeah
seven
what if that's the card you need
are you praying
no one does break that's not right
but that'll work
like something he's coming back to me i
said
are you really still going
my name is brick mercedes
well
eleven
no one wants to rock
you have wheat
get on my rock
just exchange with the bank
right now that's what i'm gonna have to
do
giving it up to the love by live
channels
[Music]
no it's actually ryan's house um why is
this
his name you can't you gotta wait well
after all first
do you have enough for a settlement
okay you won
huh you won
you got 10 points
i was about to go to settlement oh okay
in game
let's do this
i'm gonna do that
and i was gonna do this
and this
and then that would have been returning
good games
good one
three four five seven seven eight
now there we go
think swiss six
if he can scorch work
next turn great
it's only his third time playing
well my third game the second time right
yeah
we are
what do you think about the uh
aviator nation question or the ability
nation
show uh i wasn't at the actual show but
i went to the after party and saw
like it's all you guys there just to
come say hi it's pretty lit hey yeah i'm
part of school
good fun
they say nick won but hans had the
longest road
i did but everyone was really close to
it
and nick take his shirt off and flex no
they're
sorry
brad sorry i'm
brad who's i'm brad
who was
my brad that's him
i play again yeah
what time is it
i have one more of you one more
it'll be quicker this time
yeah
we didn't we it's all set up
we're not going to redo the numbers you
put the victory point back
oh you won before
because you had the victory point you
didn't count it early no
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
so we played longer than we needed
we did that last time because i didn't
realize i won
oh [ __ ] it happens
yo when you did your show after uh we
did the sausage fest yeah they smell
like beer
yeah yeah
we made sausage on the stage
and there i had a bunch of it well yeah
did you get to try mine they just
brought me a bucket all of it and i had
a little bit of water
my sausage want me an awesome night
don't play
all right
help me out
pick up the tiles and make it random
so um
what do you think about the awesome
comedy scene
i wouldn't be here if i didn't
enjoy it
for what's going on right now in the
country i think it's the best place to
be
yeah i feel the same way it's new
everything's moving it's fresh it's open
too like even like these open even open
micros are getting to perform for
crowds right now like people are showing
up to open it's a good ratio
oh yeah that's what we want
we want it we want that good fresno
feeling
yeah come to austin it's just like
fresno
and then people came to open my opinion
for valley people would come out and
free up the mics just to watch open mic
uh the good old days
we have a cousin that uh
grew up in frederick we've got there's a
m in king's canyon area
she's like that's where you just go to
the sequoia ridge
but that was called the queen of kings
canyon
actually up in king's canyon oh yeah all
the queen's vaginas
found the lovely little cabin run by a
german lady up there a cabin was run
how do you run a cabin
snowstorm we got stuck in the mountain
for two extra days with her
but she didn't charge us because of the
freak weather
i remember that one
people
are you doing the numbers
randomly
kareem's almost here
for him to start yeah
yeah let's take a little breather
one she's taking a shot after that right
i'm down for another shot
the victory shot yeah okay special
occasions
i won again that'll help perk us up too
yeah i think we
rip them
yeah
we got a couple people my brother's
watching in michigan
now that's michigan
adam is uh
what's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in general am i okay super story time
just too much huh
you've been smoking a lot of cbd i guess
too much dvd
oh sorry
so
what do you guys think about the new
york comedy scene i've never been there
it's a hoot and a holler
something like it's not like an house
kind of place there's something that
plays for the birds oh
yeah you're not jokester
so yeah
here
he's sitting here it's gonna be you
what's up dude kareem i agree i always
see you around we powdered the scene for
you
all right would you like
broccoli very green orange creamy great
are we live on myspace right now we're
live on you space tube
did you go ahead and like play people oh
dude i went twice last night brother
oh my god you and him this will be
interesting you guys are brother
arrogant confident
people call you here
you got the uh the bomb piece you're
very
if it wasn't run by the bully mick i
thought these things would be better
forever let's talk
this to disney
what have i done
big bully don't know how you've been to
every young little comics i've been
leaving to sign up anybody
that's not what's happening here
it's the first one
i don't know what's happening
why because i keep asking you the same
question what do you think about dawson
comedy scene
would you like a slice of pizza
we ran out of pizza we used a long
cinnamon stick i'm gonna work
but don't you worry we're gonna adjust
the place
double dave's yeah yeah gangnam is
closed papa john's is close
yeah we called this switch
yeah
let's back up
yeah i was about to so i changed my move
because you've got it
and legendary 12 right now
i don't know
yeah that's the benefit of coming away
american phone
the ashtrays right here
you see people let's go
[Music]
let's go let's do this
you need to be alright my first one
do you not want to do it on cameras that
way
why'd you
legal delta eight
oh yeah
no i don't [ __ ]
i mean i don't get demonetized for it so
that's all that matters right
we gotta worry more about the music for
that i know
so we could do heroin
we're already monetizing you're still
making money
thanks to the super chats
come on bucco
do the right thing
well i know what i'm doing
god damn it
damn that's the only sheep part two
your turn
first your last right
what
why did you say that
uh
so what did you do today you go to a
hockey game
did you do anything comedy related
no
what hockey teams were having
no i just played a beardy
not too far from here it's called the
pine hockey club no it's right off like
research for more
nice so you just
strap on some blades
let's go
is there a bottom or is there a top
well there's a bottom but it's filled
with green but
what is that huh oh yeah i was going to
say i was going to put all this in there
salad sounds good to me
three cheese blend i love that
[Music]
anti-inflammatory
were you guys running already you guys
already writing again he ran in one well
dude what the [ __ ] dude my second time
this is like your third time ever
playing you've won twice twice it's fine
bro it's best i really like that they're
always a little very he's a big cheater
this spider-man grinders yeah
is there something you have to tell us
yeah i'm just spider-man [ __ ] knew it
he shoots those out of his wrists
whenever you're blind
the new
spider-man if i would pick myself in
super i would say the dead pulled down
in this
dominoes good that's great i'm going to
sound great
later too they're all close yes
yeah they're using them closer
domino movie who played her i don't know
i've never seen her deadpool too what
was her
harley quinn
no the actress who played domino is it
my turn
[Music]
as well
well it's the lab
some slice
well angel
did you come here right after your game
or you went home and you showered
that's cool
yeah you guys did he called me tonight
no i was supposed to be in dallas
tonight oh you had okc and then dallas
yeah i'm sure yeah that kind of was
going to be a whole road trip
were you just going to go up to mkc and
then jump back down yeah take out
download your way back yeah the grinder
oh yeah it's right here
yeah
it should be filled it will make now i
still have like a little more traumatic
you want to put some meat in oh good
right now okay i love this salad next we
got going on
is there any green in that yeah so this
one
i felt i [ __ ] just followed right in
the city
did you get a good little reference
i'm here i tried it
yeah corner everyone everyone here
looked like they climbed professionally
he's my friend love you don't worry so
i got offer
[ __ ] she got us on that joint i got a
something
dude once oh my god
yesterday
yeah
it's like two and a half you know it
doesn't matter
buzz it gives you a head high
[Music]
whoa sorry dude yeah
oh
sorry dude specifically right who is
it's the law enforcement oh
and then
what did you roll
nine and nine
you roll the nine yes i forgot to pick
up my second establishment
oh you want to forgot to pick up my set
your establishment yes
if you don't have a nine you roll the
tent oh there's been a nine and 10 so
far if you're a gentleman and a scholar
i appreciate you well they just started
they wrecked an establishment
so absolute gentleman scholar
yeah and you got the three for your
second establishment
what was that yeah
you already got the three free no no i
just i wouldn't have picked i uh i
couldn't see what they will
it's this guy's saying that
how many games you guys play before this
just one
you bring a few last night i think
they're like
three
yeah we had a big one
yeah
and two small ones into
i got somebody have three
you're intellectually secure
yeah
yeah no yeah what anybody got hay or no
trees
no you don't don't no
yeah
yeah
hey
nice dude we love eggs
that's super drugs
grassy
it's your hot five
circle cinco cinco
[Music]
road
yeah it's about fairfire
you have a brick
you want sheep or rock
wait who are who has we
i do you know what would you do this you
about this two yeah yeah i'm done oh
wait you weren't even shooting away she
been away yeah yeah yeah sure well that
was a big dream earlier
one two three four ten
why are you rebuilding the city
uh in 13
this game you gotta make money most up
immediately
all right
four
so many of the trees i've got four and
sheep
let me give them burke
you drop something
sounds
does anybody want brick for wood
brick for wood yeah
i'm good
um
did you you just went right
you just went okay
is that how that works
yeah yeah that's i mean it's house
release i was pretty flabbergasted too
when i heard it it makes it better
but hans just put his face down
bigger tingling not like literally
yeah i mean
just
more fun that way
does anyone have a wood for a brick
no all right hold on
there we go
eleven
anyone want sheep
sorry
i made it let's see
i'm not done yet oh my
god wait who has the way
i
don't want your sheep brought on
all right let me put this this way
you guys morning
snacks on his side
i mean i'm just getting blessed right
now that's how it feels job less you
need the look
you need to know the truth
move that bus
oh my god the first one of the evening
the first question always says uh after
a seventh who says that you do
or at night like a brother
yeah i mean that's
is that from extreme home makeover i
think so
is that the people who is
i want that same tenacity
one movie
and here he is a city no it's fine great
i think he's lost
you're vulnerable
this was a don't move
to stop tim too you're not just
tendering me only
stranger no like says sourpuss
very interesting move maybe
i want to buy a tree playing guitar
about minority half minor person's
grades
you know
yeah i drop bombs
dude that means like if you could steal
people's [ __ ] instead
nobody had or you just said a
reconnaissance mission well you gotta
wait and watch yeah you're gonna see
what's happening
but you have one whole round to figure
it out
this isn't my knee and somebody having
any a tree for a rock
20.
10.
and then to break for uh what no
done once
all right well well uh two brick for a
wood i don't have any one
eight let's go
dude hans why do you do me so good
because i'm doing myself even better
player i love it
when you do it's like you're doing me
too
that's kind of cool
we should have a fireplace
elise i'm doing really good right
you're now of me
i'm very proud
thank you makes you in a better mood for
our tree i don't know how this guy
happens
i look at what i'm on
salary
had to drive much unless he wants him
how many do you have now
four
three five three
what did he
yeah
but you're right there like you have an
extra route you have two extra rounds
let me tell you from homes
shaped [ __ ] it does he like did
against me like whoa bro what
you take it personally yeah 100
or maybe he's just stupid i think that's
a big part of
taking it personally exactly
you can control everything right more of
the speed roll come on there's no trade
i was at nine times are you done right
now i love i [ __ ] love searching dude
hey let's
go that's him man
i would debated building on that aim oh
yeah
that's [ __ ]
not cool
that is cool and that's what you want me
to say
yeah i know but i also stopped the
settlement
why oh that's the number five
you know what they were a lot of eight
was you know who rolled the five yeah
look we're tied now
you know you gotta be
the
just
clicking
that was
just
so great
i'm trying to lean forward a little bit
do you wanna pick a card from you
[Music]
dramatic role in the leverage
hopes i'll sell god
are you
sorry
usually a guitar and you pass the squire
the dice and uh
but if you're not you're a gesture it's
fine i know you're
i'm kidding you don't play through the
box
i got it
um
[Music]
hey
the ones rock
yeah for what we
no
or what uh
screwed up bro from that
wood
uh no i got winter wheat for rock
what are we what am i
i said
so they'll foreign versions
going
oh red stag longus
road
do you want to give this buyer to this
fella
don't call this no
no i don't know
it sounds like it though
congratulations
it's getting there why this you
you gotta stop
at all
anybody need ore
yeah
believe it okay yeah probably yeah
would you like
um
what for another hey yeah
i'm good you're good you're good yes you
got your answer
six
five
anyone want wood
what brick
what about rock
or we
well
i'll deal
what
no i was looking at that and i was like
i'm gonna go there soon what am i ever
gonna roll 12 and he goes 12.
go [ __ ] figure
oh
now
[Music]
nick you got a nine
i'm building a rev run
wood two for one weight
does anyone
have
a rock first sheep
right now
no
no one can do a rock for hay
no no i need a sheep no one i gotta see
anybody need this for uh do you want to
rock them the purple thing with the
trash do you have a tree too
i i was gonna use it
um all right moving to settlement so
would
this that two for one bridge
would you want to be a brick my best
four right
two for one here this element i didn't
see eight or two
that's all your uh [ __ ] that's all your
settlements right now you're
now you have to build cities
oh [ __ ] say you're right
that's pretty wild could have been one
pictures
i don't know it's crazy we said you
wrote decks through the six
[Music]
who has brick
and sheep
who has sheep
but we
i don't want sheep rock or wheat
what do you want for the weed
yeah wait oh you need week
no i just
wait what do you want for the week
uh you're going to give me weight no
you're going to give me weed oh i need
brick
i don't remember what about sheep no
what do you have you would
would
give you
four for one
or hate for one lord
what do you have
got one yellows
hey
have sheep
no i have one tree for a hay
i need
i'll give you this much for a brick
jeez louise i have no cars i need bricks
you got a brick
your best exciting haul brother
all right i don't even want to play with
you
concussion
[Music]
what are you doing why wouldn't you
build bear why would i you would have
had a poor and don't you need
oh i guess you're on rock already
now you're trying to [ __ ] me dude
oh you're gonna build there
oh wait you're right fan
well you can no you can't you're good
everybody still can
six
is
for a break
pick up some paws
[Music]
no you have one two three four five six
seven you have somebody from him on the
roads i thought you might points oh no
no i just meant rugs yeah
and you can [ __ ] him but he can at least
go back down with you and see if did you
ask
anyone i need tree for hay
anyone need trees
i'm just leaving trees
giving away trees if anyone wants to
getting a good deal on trees
if not i will go ahead and with my
children
seven
oh that's fair no it's personal
[ __ ]
the fact
that lumber i didn't know what to do
with that winter was coming i didn't
want to cover it wouldn't you go forward
dude yeah it's doors
straight in the woods
think you have two points yes no
i have um five let's do an update you
have something we have five
so five five
four
two two
okay
dude what are you doing i just put that
down all right
yeah
i want to skip this
they don't give a music request yeah
anyone want wood or wheat for a sheep
what was this wood or wheat or sheep i
need word we need one hey brick
that's uh
that's wild you get four sheep
on that nine
i know
you're gonna build that with all your
sheep yeah
four
[ __ ] dave oh it's a five we're good
also sleeping wrong
[Music]
does anybody have brick
for what
for wood
for
[Music]
for wood no do you have any rock or
wheat
i have rock i'll give you one for one
can you give me a two can you give me a
wooden rock for a break
oh willing
for bro
yeah that's my offer okay
thank you
yeah
yeah i can pack that thing up if you
guys want i think he said there should
still be something in there yeah yeah
there's a world
oh yeah i mean i i'd like to smoke some
more i guess
you guys want to do dmt
oh castle anybody can break all right
i mean where are you from
you know water
yeah
i don't even necessarily what
oh
the old guy what a good deal
but no you need to make something happen
dude
he cut me off i give him good price dude
yeah i give you a lot i give you good
price but you're all
four quattros
you have a lot for that
you know some money moves right click
hold up
actually
[Music]
[Music]
it's one two places away and you have
two roads what are you talking about but
yeah because you're wrong
it doesn't matter yeah you also have the
two roads and look i'm more than two
places away if my house was here you
would not be able to if this house was
fierce oh yeah this house was here you
would not be able to go there
yeah that's pretty insane plum
this one
right hans can you build a crib right
here since yeah
yeah
everyone can build there except me
i should have built that i don't have
any more homes i sold them all well you
could build a city
at the bruce roll it's a huh oh yeah
seven
do you have anyone
determine our thing
oh nice i think i've been taking the the
freshies
back more yeah so everyone can get a
good yeah
and all the friends again i can't tell
that it's like dance or not
but it's grinding so it's funny
maybe i should have got that port i
should have went for it
i don't know why you were building
inlets
it's not maybe because there's more dots
over there
mine
jerry
there you go
who's jared
all right look at that that was great
dude looking to be smoking on its own
it's like a good cigar how fast it is i
didn't know if you were or not because
you said you were
is it you're a little
excited that's really back there
it should be cherry
is it not
did everybody have those a big head do
you need to like this
place
it's tossed and you mastered
does anybody have lead
i got rocker i got rockers for
the heat
rocks bricks or once i got rock or work
okay
okay
did you do that
does that mean
that those are you
oh well
came back around fast
did you you did a passion why oh
[Music]
yeah because it's still the pace thing
away and there's two
roads on either side
yeah i don't know you could be illegal
would you backtrack well no because all
he's doing is placeholding where he
could build but it goes back to the rule
well that's just good to know for a few
dreams
question i just that's cool to learn
that's a good uh strategy
perfect exactly just even holding it if
you can or keep going
six
i would love to you know
pick up some cards to play with you guys
does anyone have any hey
this thing is cursing me i have to play
this
thing you look at her
dude i know way too much about the world
right now actually uh let's bring it
right here we gotta put her back back in
for him
he's
stupid apple
you want to play at night
thank you bro
oh i don't know
i'll say i gotta take from home
me yeah he doesn't have any
that's your girl dude is she brave
she great guys
anybody need any wood
for hay
wood for wheat
is that a milk i don't know
i'm sorry all right i'll pass them
you need to play it after your role no
you can play before right right after
you work yeah you can play before really
yeah do you just kids you just can't
play when you pick it up
what
let's go here
you play it before after you're rolling
basically you stole from me before
you know i'm taking it from you he
already stole from me
shift both of you
five six seven
that's what you [ __ ] block
oh not that's wait come on hold on
like that
what's up
it's a compliment you're a threat
you took that card back
hmm
people bigger than one of them
six
his life was self-serving
i was just lying for the chaos isn't him
dude being lying you're crying my dad
always said
well man oh my goodness we love those
stupid 12.
12.
yeah oh nice
thank you
that was the second problem by the way
anybody need wood or sheep for hay
okay
five
[Music]
nice see that's exactly what i'm going
to
have
there we go
you take from one of them oh sorry
again
this is like the fourth time you guys
have done this
can you do that
you can take from wherever you want well
dude what the [ __ ]
that's seven i know what it's like to be
in june
wait did you have to drop you wrote was
seven yeah yeah or ten i was seven
and i forgot i almost passed through
that thing about [ __ ] a card
i feel like i've been gone persecution
is real
this thing's moving along eight nice we
love those
i'm excited to brick for a hey
oh
he got it
we won one
no oh don't say that even close
i think he got nothing
david six
yeah five
you have three five four
six
it's
six
i'm going to roast
that on two books
lose that
six
yeah you just got all that wood and you
see more she goes
don't have a night card i guess
who's trying is it my chance
um
who wants wheat
i need raw i got turkey
i won't leave for
you want to lovely it again no
i got crazy
i'm down there
i mean can you guys put it
on
like i don't want it
a wheat for a rock yeah
oh are we for two trees
yeah
oh strokes let's go
we want this first
that'd be sick that you got two by the
stripes
one two three that's two rocks
who wants sheep
someone
it's like throwing michelle and mario
target everyday
we'll just pour out a little bit what do
you mean
you're rubbing out oh my god you're
gonna figure
yeah
pretty much
it's coming back to the big city
you're moving digging out of
seven
moving to south i'm
to the south yeah
it's nice
so what do you think about all this
violence on sixth street has been
violence yeah all the time there's
shootings well i live on fifth street
perfect
we're at fifth and the one in balance
it's called out in monarch the monarch
what's the cross streets fifth
west west
west fifth and one about west it's west
ave and then it's oh west uh yeah
traders uh streaming west
to austin come on
yeah where are you not in texas
in texas
yeah no in this city of austin oh
go
yeah i'm moving to the south
eight right yeah
come on
five
right
who wants to do dmt
i'm not knocked out
where did you put it
who has the longest road
i lost it so i'm down to four and then
correctly sandra's a percentage of
the sound with another road just so i
can lock it in
because if you built one more you would
have taken it from me
but now i locked it down
wow
we'll grind it out here these
so i'd like to do it
so let's roll for myself
butch roll for the rest of y'all
hmm
this is uh all off the dome yeah
and no seriously
i can't get into my other account on my
youtube for my animal product so
i'm gonna do it for my tv
you know
six
six
from you
good
does anybody
i like this alone how many do we have
rock for trees
[Music]
i like this song too a lot let's go i'll
give it a brick for a tree
let's be friends
yeah
that works for trent
hmm
of course
i felt pretty rude
but that breaks that you know right yeah
i know it doesn't count those two
you're gonna start afresh
jesus christ
well this is so nervous yeah it's just
kind of happening
you can build now
it comes up settlement
four
is that what's blocked over here oh why
am i keeping it four
12.
that gives you enough for two more
no no i tapped on anyways i thought you
know oh yeah
well i need to make other movements
right now
it was wood
oh oh it's just turning back now
it was sheep
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't have a rock
so it's
this is the second half game plan now
ten
only
give me
normal silhouette
ten
ten years
two
i'll get a dab card
i
want a three for one
for a week
your green
yeah
nine
what's
[Music]
okay everyone give me your wheat
you don't have any i have this much
it's nice
here i'll show it to the world so they
believe this
obama's watching this
you know what about me dude he looks
sweet
my cat
you can't sleep so
yeah that's odd see that's that's
awesome two cats one's obama the other
michael sarah
that's amazing obama's got a big goal on
his side that's fantastic obama for
choosing a different meeting
i can't say it's foreign
yes
we'll get a development card and do a
rocket landing rocker
are we
how can you do two broth
two bricks or
two or two burgundy or a wheat how can
you do that yeah you don't have a report
you're not gonna before your own part
i can do that he's actually on the board
yeah he's stolen valor
he's actually a veteran
um
what else did you take your other stuff
back
yeah
there's video footage
but truthful for male 1
6
6 5.
anybody needs sheep or hay
for what a break for brick
how many rows you know that's a billy
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten oh you can't build three all right
i'll give you two break first she's
gonna hey
wait actually
nah
i can't trade you
dude how about you i don't have brooke
dude
right bro i'll give you two for one i'll
give you one brick first first sheep
rock
no all right we're good yeah
i would do one for one what was that no
one sheep for one brick
oh jeff that's such a [ __ ] hey yeah we
love it
um
what do you guys think about i'll sign
the knight card i don't know why i
didn't put that forward don't matter
who's winning
you are he's han yeah block yourself
wait that's can i do that
are you highly can i block myself
yo how many you got there brother is
that eight
you played at night
always watching dude i got eyes in front
of my head
dude um wait hold on hey you haven't
rolled yet
yeah he didn't like that i did just i
just did and i'm about to buy that card
okay i play my night
i move this back here
and it's take from you
for me yeah cool obviously you are
okay completely useless
eight
only eight as well
oh eights we love those
who wants brick
you have rock
that's sheep and hay
uh you get one devs card
yeah do you use drop at night
yeah so you gotta move the [ __ ] thing
now it did yeah
dude that's not great if you put it on
me
you put it on me i put it on you
sleeper you're gonna watch him what are
you at now eight points that's what i'm
saying he's this is the show you get it
all
okay i'm done
you know thumb
it's actually kind of funny
11
11.
kind of christmasy a spooky way
roads
this song is so weird
who is this
it's called chris chelsea
it's nice
me i have a lot of weird ones underneath
my uh skull one two three four five
it's got five points
holding them but you gotta you gotta
move it i know i'm figuring out does
anyone have over eight how many you got
a lot of cards in your hand no i only
have yeah those though what are these
called development cards
yes so what
oh
such a long time
how many times would i have a draw two
tip
one man's treasure is another man's
truck
i got a development card
stay
many six is for old threesome
i'm playing a year of flight aids and
buying that bug
does anybody need anyone no all right
try eleven
cents a blah blah
blah
huh literally said it should flock a
level
you know whatever
that was last question
okay everyone give me a rock
only one
from
let's actually turn point it's not good
anyone want brick
sheet per sheet yeah two brick one
because then i can take the points from
here i don't have any
i need it man
it just [ __ ] up right
now you guys i respect this from you
broken hands
i don't know man
okay i play at night
i don't play that song because i just
picked it up but i have this one i can
play
and i steal how many days oh i should
have moved it before that's like four
move it here or my biggest threat still
this isn't cheap
that's what being really it feels like
it's totally all i have i just don't
hold that who would
who wants wood
sheep i need sheep
okay
dude
you're done yeah sorry
seven
seven nice
um
wait those are all developing parts yeah
church right now
how did this game go right now i'm going
to play the ninth
general seven i don't have any cards by
the way why would you play the night
because i'm going to keep my return so
i'm trying to play cards and [ __ ] okay
it's like black on black violence
does anyone
have prick
their much great so who do you think is
like
one of the top dogs in austin comedy
right now
yeah
dean stanfield no i don't have any cards
huge brick
no
you don't have any brick oh we got wood
i won't even name your price
um do you see a tree for a rock
oh my god
i'll give you give me brick i don't have
any brand i'll give you two rocks
[Music]
hey man if you want to take me that's
cool
seven
do you have over seven
how close is he to getting longest road
that's what i'm saying like everyone
doesn't like you guys are attacking them
the wrong guy
it's not good
this would be a gaslighting field if
you're into the last ones and you're
about you're hiding at the point too
do you have nine points again not
necessarily
true that's probably five points
on this forty seven five parts it's just
three more
late night
over here still for me
a little money
he took three wood for me in a row at
the rate
what
[ __ ] you gonna do with that
at least you don't have that right we
need sheep to eat dude our people are
starving yeah
and you know i never built some city
people my name six
[ __ ] six man
out of sixes
i got two road building cards for no
reason
i don't even need roads
these four you can bring in a big
meeting with the belt throughout the
spring yeah
there's no use that i can't trade
development guys you can't no
do you trade your mother
exactly
she's developing ovarian cancer
go on some water
one
six
oh my goodness
so who's like some guy that you see in
the scene that you're like man this guy
is thinks to high heaven
when he's on stage it's just like a pu
for a brick
and then so many people come to mind
yeah i'm gonna take the longest road
hold on i've i've 13.
hold up
i'm losing boards
yeah
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 twelve thirteen
whoa hold on of course good
luck you're [ __ ] dude hold on can we
run that replay back
um
was that legal what did you say
probably yeah why wouldn't it be am i
being gaslighted right now no
is this what it is
it doesn't count these two you're
telling us
no no you're good they said it's legal
are you i just got back from my studio
be my turn i'm just people at her
because that was
always your plan
i needed those points saying obama would
watch him say
hey
i can't sure build on my leg
four
play a knight
take
from
i mean one two three four
i just walked through four five one two
three four you're back and you're
packing elements attacking items i'm
about to honorably discharge myself
i feel like he's got this
he's got to be at that point
okay
he lied to us he said oh i have this
road building car that was good he's
gonna buy a bro he wants we i need rock
he's gonna buy a development card
yeah wants wood i need rock
three wood for one rod
sorry
one wood for one week
one two
three four
still trying to get the best deal even
though he could have gotten it the whole
time
it's [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
too predictable right for trying to get
the best deal if you want four minutes
can't do it you gotta roll first wow
because what if you have over seven
cards
six
all right
four for one week
i'm gonna build
this
oh my god what a dumb move that was all
right
could have doubled this up
you have so many more dots you put you
doubled up on a one dot oh look we have
four rounds
well
i could always switch it
this third fun plane don't want to get
into my 40th time
right now you literally took your hand
off my apparently that one i can tell
you guys a fun fact the next time the us
lightning
that's long
dude it's like yeah it's electricity
electricity is really weird
this is newsworthy
thank you
i thought
well those were four were for a sheep
that's gonna be
two
[Music]
everyone's supposed to have fun playing
the time
only with people waiting imagine
i can't believe you're that many
development person
you took a [ __ ]
nuts you never see that no
see hasn't played it
like i can't wait to run back the tape
and see how much
collusion was important yes game didn't
even
take like four cards at a time
i have
sheep for rock
i read for rock
i have wood for rock
oh you have the mustache
no
that's brave i think it'll go right over
my ankle just fine here man
well i'm glad you had a good time here
well thank you for showing me the
greatest time ever i appreciate you i'm
glad that you thought it was so great
and that it wasn't boring and depressing
and sad and nerdy
i mean i really popped a lot of pills to
enjoy but you know
guys
so that's the good thing is there's
plenty of drugs in this house
yeah
dragon is where my home is
[Music]
hold on
okay so we probably took like now you've
been like what like maybe twenty seven
yeah
less than that
[Music]
but i think since we um
maybe i don't know i had some chocolate
earlier maybe that's probably why you
know so strong
animals
today
did did we
i hope so
maybe
i need that i need a hay
you shoot for a week
no i can't do that did anybody have a
shoes
not a sheep like sheep uh for a brick
yeah right
did you fart grab that card no that was
my my friend
his face furthered
you stop farting through your face
everyone has facial hair except me and
at least no i have a little bit of you
know well
one two three
four five i think i might have done
something a little bit into it check
this please tell me
we would have rock
no one would really have rock
white or red might have rock
i don't person
i built my city with my room
what's that your current no i said
that's not toronto i said that's all my
raw
oh
um
okay well i don't believe you
it's the next video
should you guys take a phone camera
you know
you're nowhere near rock
never mind i went
yeah
awkward
yes
that was
one two three four five six
two devi cards two by two points an army
isn't it
flawless victory
so awesome miss hans
you know you cut me off
but instead of growing outward i grew
inward and learned develop myself
through development cards
look at this a university
and a chapel
what do you have you philistines i am
i got a long road over yonder
yeah i don't stretch chasing you for the
long run
sometimes a wasted uh meeting god damn
look at all these development cards i
use
two of them
you can pull in knights didn't you yeah
and longer two longest roads which were
useless
what a game what a night
so
what do you think about the scene in
austin right now
i think tonight there's brett morin at
the velken
such a nice guy so funny so great
effortless for that guy it's great to
see
and then gerard's carmichael
what are you talking about i'm guessing
they're sold out
i know jerry carmichael's you're sold
out
yeah it's a it's really topping it's a
lot of stages
what local shows are going on tonight
there was the hotel one there was mad
house
mad house what's mad house
lucas doesn't know what that
oh uh lucas mccrory main court main
course oh yeah
is that a spider fire house
virus lounge a little bar under the
hostel
it's cool little room i think it's
closeness to everything is really going
to make it a nice uh
second spot late night comedy room yeah
after rose opens up
yeah rogans
they just call it rogan's
come down come on down to yo rogans
where you're gonna have to learn to
defend a choke
everyone's choking each other all the
time
it's just a [ __ ]
fight
so we got the ones nick and hans
we might play another game okay
i am going to do it
yeah
i gotta be able to do the bomb
oh
sounds good though just leave it out all
right
i was told